uh there needs to be a lot of uh
well you could say investigative
journalism done on this but of course
who's going to allow you to report
unless you have an independent platform
uh
on the reality of what's going on uh
i've heard of some of the
social media platforms banning um
attempts to expose this a contact of
mine tried to expose this on his
facebook page and it got suspended
but it's worth trying to expose it's
worth
trying to get a word out i think maybe
youtube might be one way of doing it but
you have to try and get to the hospitals
and do some filming
and investigations uh
as to how
crowded or not crowded those hospitals
are
um and
look deeper below below the surface on
what the government's claiming
right well i mean you mentioned that
mainly
politicians and celebrities and elites
are involved in the satanic ritual abuse
but also a lot of ordinary people as
well
why don't you hear about more people
being exposed
uh before i go into that before i forget
just the last point about the kobe 19.
about one year before the kobe 19
lockdown
in january 2019 i
interviewed an sra survivor
who very unusually because it's not
common among sra survivors to
to say that they experienced this um
this was in england
he told me that when he was
a child not only did he
suffer sra from satanists but they were
also conducting medical experiments on
him
and the medical experiments were all
about infectious diseases
infectious diseases like for example
covet 19.
of course covar19 did not exist back
then
they were looking at how to manufacture
an infectious disease the satanist
and they were looking at how to create a
vaccine
for the infectious disease not out of
the goodness of their heart but to
create
leverage over those who suffer from the
illness
and also to protect themselves probably
and when the corporate 19 pandemic broke
out i asked him a few questions
including do you think it was uh
experiments on you to create an
infectious disease
like kobe 19. i think kopi 19 is
probably a human engineer
virus secondly
to create a vaccine for it so that they
could use it as leverage over others
and he said yes all of that
that's what he believes he was
experimented on for and he actually
brought me to the medical research labs
in england
where there's still research going on
today
a lot of it is on the surface at least
legitimate research
some of them are owned by pharmaceutical
companies
and how would they use the vaccines as
leverage
well for example
if there was a human engineer
virus that was so difficult to contain
and deal with except by vaccine
and they the satanist had the vaccine
access to it they could basically get
people to do what they want
in order to obtain the vaccine couldn't
they
because it's a matter of life and death
and so
he who controls the vaccine will control
the world if it's a world pandemic
and if it's a real pandemic not not
just jacked up numbers but the real
thing that people
are really dying in large numbers people
will do practically anything
to to get their vaccine so from satanist
it could be
well you do what we want or you sign up
to become a satanist and then we'll give
you the vaccine
right amazing form of controlling people
especially if they're worried that
without the vaccine they will die
so maybe um
this is what the real story is behind
the covet 19 but i would say it's
probably
if it was engineered by this agent is
it's probably a test run
for something even bigger to come at
some point in the future
it's a test run because
what may come in the future maybe even
worse
when you have people on their knees
before the satan is
wanting the vaccine the only lifesaver
that they can obtain
uh to protect them and their loved ones
from a really a real killer infectious
disease that's
that would make covet 19 look like a
walk in the park
i know this is a very pessimistic view
but i also know that the way the
satanists operate they tend to
[Music]
they tend to be very ambitious they tend
to think big
in evil terms so they they usually have
bigger plans of evil to implement than
what we see now
but this is for the future so
i find it a very interesting and
disturbing coincidence
that they will have this interest in
medical experiments on infectious
diseases and then now we have this
huge problem with copet19
yeah but wouldn't i mean wouldn't a
country
just as much want to do something like
that experiment with expect
infectious diseases to use them as
bio weapons against other countries i
mean what would it
wouldn't like a a country a a rival
country want to do the same thing
yeah that's true but why would satanists
be involved
in this program why would they put their
human subjects
through sra that is my
my big concern you see if it was for
example
our intelligence agencies in the uk
running these experiments
and there was no sra then i would
conclude that it's probably
an intelligence agency going rogue
so to speak beyond the boundaries of the
authority
in order to find a
effective bioweapon they could use as
part of their
military defense of the country but
what we have instead are satanists
involved and doing sra to their
experimental subject
at the same time as also um
on other days doing medical experiments
on on the person
uh the government
agencies probably the intelligence
agencies had
some involvement in this or awareness at
least of this
i asked the survivor where he thought
the
files on the results of his experiments
would be
kept because he's been wondering where
he could get the paperwork on the
experimentation done on him
because there would also be proof of
what he
he went through and he concluded that
it's probably
with the intelligence agencies in the uk
and that he will be able to access it
because of that
so yes there was probably some
intelligence agency involvement but the
lead
seemed to be taken by the satanist
rather than the intelligence agency
uh the satanists do have their own
people in the intelligence agencies
uh so that they may there was probably
an overlap
but where the satanists are involved
it's usually
them taking the lead whether overtly or
covertly they are taking the lead
you can be quite sure of that and why
would the satanist be so interested
in experimenting on someone regarding
infectious diseases so you think there's
satanists working within these
government agencies
that are potentially developing
chemical weapons or bio
warfare weapons because you know i
wouldn't expect some
satanic cult to have the money
to do this kind of thing to to conduct
these sort of experiments
and to invest in in scientists that know
what the
what what they're doing yes you're right
they would they would tap into
government money they would use their
contacts with government
uh they are satanists in government and
in the civil service
uh even our ex-prime minister edward
heath
had had at least six independent
witnesses
accusing him of satanic abuse
what was he saying so uh edward heath he
is he was the
conservative uk prime minister in the
1970s
just before margaret thatcher
and he there was a
as we've several the investigation was
done after he died
years after he died but the
police in wheelchair which is one of the
counties in england
uh because edward heave lived there they
led
an investigation into allegations of
edward heaps child sex abuse and edward
heaves
satan satan is ritual abuse
and they concluded in their report which
is on the internet by the way
operation conifer it was called
operation conifers
summary closure report
stated that six
people said that edward heath did
satanic satanic abuse to them
for years uh i have known from
from various sources that edward heath
was involved in sra
but at last we had a police
investigation that officially
concluded that he had six
witnesses uh these six witnesses
who corroborated each other that edward
he was involved in satanic abuse
that's a large number for any sex
offense
to have six witnesses
uh because the very nature of sex
offenses as you know usually
it's difficult to find more than one
witness who is the victim
but it shows you how prolific heath was
in his abuse both his child sex abuse
and his satanic abuse
and he is the former prime minister of
the uk
i